in the high-profile trial of theranos
founder elizabeth holmes prosecutors
have been trying to prove that holmes
intentionally defrauded patients and
investors by making false claims about
her company's blood testing technology
holmes has pleaded not guilty this
company is about being able to change
the health care industry as prosecutors
continue to make their case speculation
has grown about whether holmes will take
the stand all these witnesses we've
heard from have said
how they were totally enamored by her
they totally believed her she had a
presence that controlled her room to
catch you up on three key pieces of
evidence presented at trial so far and a
look at what's to come we talked to wall
street journal reporter sarah randazzo
who's been covering the trial in
california
first audio recordings have given jurors
the chance to hear holmes pitch theranos
to investors in 2013. the ability to
take a technology like this and put it
in flight specifically on a medevac has
the potential to change survival rates
we're hearing elizabeth holmes touting
how they can do all of these things with
the machines how they're working with
the military and the military is huge
for them and so all of these things that
at this point the jurors have heard uh
contained a lot of falsehoods and
weren't quite true and so now they're
hearing elizabeth holmes say it directly
which is pretty powerful some investors
said holmes's promise to help members of
the military compel them to invest in
the company in cross-examination
attorneys for homes have made the case
that theranos investors should have
asked questions if they had concerns and
that they knew investing in a new type
of technology like the kind theranos was
developing came with risks prosecutors
also read private text messages between
holmes and her former boyfriend sonny
balwani who is the number two at the
company there's a lot of texts showing
sunny and elizabeth texting about
concerns or things that they're worried
about in one 2015 message following
media appearances made by holmes balwani
wrote fyi i am worried about
overexposure without solid substance
which is lacking right now holmes
responded that the media coverage helped
theranos get a business deal it's
important because a big part of this
trial is showing elizabeth holmes's
intent and that she intended to deceive
so if jurors can come to believe that
she thought there were a bunch of
concerns but then publicly was saying
nothing was wrong
that can help them in their
deliberations the defense has argued
that holmes relied on balwani for
accurate information about the company
and that she believed she was telling
the truth about theranos bawani who
faces his own separate trial has denied
any wrongdoing
another key piece of evidence shown by
the prosecution an allegedly forged
endorsement this document emblazoned
with the pfizer logo purported to show
that theranos's technology had been
validated by the pharmaceutical giant
but prosecutors say it was used to
deceive investors what's come out is
that they did work with pfizer in the
very early years of the company pfizer
then had a scientist shane webber
analyze everything that they'd seen and
internally write a report that concluded
they didn't want to pursue the
relationship weber said he himself told
holmes that pfizer wasn't interested in
working with theranos but about a year
later theranos put out a report with the
pfizer logo on it which holmes used to
pitch to investors some investors
testified that they took the report at
face value and that it played into their
decision to invest many millions of
dollars of course there's been plenty of
other evidence presented at trial so far
which you can read more about at wsj.com
so what's next in the closely watched
trial the defense will soon have a
chance to make its case and it could go
a few different ways as lawyers
suggested in a court filing they could
argue that holmes was in an abusive
relationship with balwani that left her
under his control a lawyer for balwani
disputed any allegations of abuse or as
the defense argued in opening statements
it could continue making the case that
holmes simply had a startup that failed
like many others in silicon valley the
defense could also simply rest hoping
that prosecutors didn't prove holmes's
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt i think
it's going to be a bit of a
surprise you know and shocked moment in
court when they stand up and say whether
they're calling someone or just you know
resting the case holmes is facing 12
counts of wire fraud and conspiracy to
commit wire fraud with the top charges
carrying a maximum federal prison
sentence of 20 years